baseball you said something yesterday
right you said something yesterday about
baseball said baseball is the most
boring sport and they're using audience
why right did you have a reason for it
or were you just asking because you
wanted to know
well there's uh so I started looking at
the the revenue that comes in for Major
League Baseball and I was actually
surprised how little of it is actually
Television right or is is
um the tickets that are that are sold uh
and a lot of it's television rights but
the reality is who enjoys watching
baseball on television anymore it's a
small minority of the population I think
they're they have to find a way to sexy
it up there has to be something and so I
was asking Pat because we all know that
he has the entrepreneur the
entrepreneurial mind what could be done
to baseball to I don't know bring back
the Mystique bring back the fun
make baseball great again what can we do
okay because baseball's great but it's
very very boring
do you know why you know why baseball's
boring tell me why is baseball boring do
you actually know or no you don't know
why today slow and long why is it boring
and slow and long today
it's become a pitchers duel let me tell
you I never went to a game watching and
saying oh my gosh one zero hell yeah
what a freaking great game you went to a
gaming you want to see what home run
let's see Home Run we need to bring back
the steroids we need to bring back the
stuff by the way make steroids great as
crazy as that sounds to you as crazy as
that sounds you sound that crazy every
team's value would go up if there were
more home runs if there's more home runs
uh there'd be more accepting behind it
but right now it's more of a math if you
go to the um uh you go to see NBA you
want to see scoring you don't want to
see an eight uh 81 it's a 79 games did
you watch this year's NBA All-Star Game
in February did you watch it
did you really miss it don't tell me you
missed no no I watch I watched I watch a
dunk contest I watch the skills but did
you watch the All-Star game they don't
play defense it's just fourth quarter
Adam they play D in the fourth quarter
they change into the fourth quarter
that's right greatest deal they changed
in the fourth quarter so that's right
that's right you're absolutely right
greatest you're right quarter I've ever
seen in the history absolutely right I
could not believe it and who won
LeBron's team well the whole thing was
about defense yes you have just in the
fourth quarter it was sick because it
was like the first team to get 150.
it was awesome the model they change so
here's what's the point there here's the
point the NBA All-Star game for the
longest time has been boring what are
you watching it for no one plays defense
that's a lab you throw it around and
it's like ah who cares who wins this
year they change it up I think MLB needs
to sit down just like a sales
organization needs to change a
compensation structure sometimes yeah I
think the MLB needs to first fire Rob
man for it was the worst freaking
commissioner out there 60 games they're
talking about the fact that even the
games you can't be six feet Within each
other you yeah you literally are going
to get ejected if you come six feet from
another player for the terms or the the
Umpire like to go argue a call if if you
come within six feet you're
automatically ejected with get this a
suspension and a fine now in a 60-game
season start thinking about how
important a suspension is like if you're
out for five games or ten games like
that's that's well usually you'd get
suspended 60 games for steroids so you
know you get caught you're out for the
whole season
I don't know I think they need to change
the compensation structure in the in the
in the game of baseball and what I mean
by that is the way the game is set up
right now it's too slow kids are not
going to like I had a buddy of mine this
guy is all about baseball and he's all
about pitching we'd go to a game and he
would say this is a great pitching game
wow what a great game we're at I'm like
what a great what a nurse sixth inning
and it's zero zero this is a ten no no
no no watch this look at the strategy
look at the pitch they've already
switched two times and look what they're
doing the guy's still throwing a 98 I
said I don't care about a 98 mile
fastball you know what I care about I
care about a 450 foot home run that's
what I care about we gotta get something
you know it would go up I mean I
remember I went to a game one time the
the Texas Rangers play the uh Angels
back in the days the Angels had salmon
and the Rangers said Juan Gonzalez at
this game Juan Gonzalez at two home runs
at this hero your favorite player my
favorite baseball player two home runs
you remember those types of games yeah
you can't remember a pitching dude when
it comes down to baseball they got to
figure out a way to change the pitching
game
[Music]